KATHERINE KUAN: Hello.
My name is Katherine Kuan,
and I'm a developer advocate
on the Developer Relations
team here at Google.
Today, I'll be talking
about Google Play services.
For those of you who
don't know what it is,
it's a way for us to provide
new APIs to developers
on a regular basis that
will work on devices running
the latest operating system,
all the way back to Gingerbread.
It contains great APIs, such
as Location, Games, Wallet, G+,
and much, much more.
You can leverage all of
these to create amazing apps
for your users.
To use these APIs,
you can access them
through the Google Play
services app, which
is delivered to users'
devices through Google Play,
and updated automatically.
With the most recent
release of the app,
we're moving to a new
model for how developers
like you can interact
more consistently
with these services.
Don't worry though.
If you've previously integrated
with Google Play services,
nothing changes for your
existing apps in the wild.
The binary interface of the
Google Play services app
remains the same.
So previously compiled
apps will continue to work.
In today's DevByte,
I'll cover why
we need this change,
what it is and how
to implement it, and
step through an example
together with you.
So let's begin with the basics.
To use all the great APIs
provided by the Google Play
services app, you
need to first open up
a client connection
to that process.
To do this, you include
the Google Play services
SDK in your app.
And call into the SDK to
set up the connection.
Now, there used to
be a different client
for each service, such as
the PlusClient, GamesClient,
AppStateClient, and so on.
To use three services, you would
have to create three clients,
and manage independent
connections
with slightly different nuances.
Fortunately, with this new and
simplified interaction model,
you will only need a
single GoogleApiClient
to connect to the Google
Play services app.
When you set up the
client, you specify
whichever APIs you want to use.
This greatly improves
the developer experience
because you only have
one client to worry
about connecting and
handling Callbacks for.
Let's talk about
how to implement it
by seeing some examples of
how you would initialize
the GoogleApiClient.
This shows you how
to add the Wallet API
and specify an account.
This shows the
Plus API and scope.
Drive API and scope.
And now, the real
difference is that now you
can add multiple APIs
and scopes easily,
which is a huge win in terms
of saving you development time
and complexity.
So once you have initialized
a client with the APIs
you need, you have to
connect and implement
Callbacks for the single
GoogleApiClient, as seen here.
After you have a
connected GoogleApiClient,
how do you access the
methods in the API?
We can look at the case
of Games as an example.
The previous model
involved calling
into the GamesClient
as the main entrypoint
to get things like
achievements and leaderboards.
But that is now
being deprecated.
So should we call it
on GoogleApiClient
because that's the replacement?
Well, we can't because it's
not coupled to any service.
And we don't want it to
know about all the methods
that each service could
potentially provide.
Instead, the answer is to
use the new entrypoints
that we've created.
In the Games case,
the main entrypoint
is now the Games
class, which offers
static methods to
read or write data.
You can access game achievements
through the Games dot
Achievements class, or a
leaderboard through the Games
dot Leaderboards
class, and so on.
Every time you make
a call to an API,
you must pass the
GoogleApiClient object as well.
This serves as a reminder that
you need an open connection
to the Google Play services
app in order for the request
to be handled.
For more detail, you can check
out the documentation or sample
games apps using
the provided link.
Now, after you
call an API, we've
standardized it so that you
get a pending result back.
PendingResult is typed so
that you can expect the answer
that you're waiting for
to be of type result.
You can wait synchronously
for the result as seen here,
or you can set an AsynchCallback
to notify you later
when the result is ready.
Result is an interface that
the services use to return you
the data you've requested, and
it has a Get Status method.
The status object tells
you information about
whether or not the result
was successful and uses
a standard set of status codes.
Then you can proceed
and use the results.
To review everything
we went over,
let's walk through an example.
We are fetching the visible
people in a user's G+ circles,
which can be
useful, for example,
to create a social
experience in an app.
First, we set up
the GoogleApiClient
and set the Plus, API, Scope,
and Connection Callbacks.
Then we implement
the Callback methods
for Connection Succeeded,
Suspended, or Failed.
The connection could
fail because it
requires user intervention.
For example, to
choose an account.
Then an intent would be returned
in the connection result.
And you should allow the
user to resolve the problem
and connect again.
Next, we call Connect
and Disconnect
on the GoogleApiClient.
As soon as the
connection is successful,
we can fetch the
information our app
needs by calling a
static method in the API
which is Plus dot People
API dot load Visible.
And we pass in the
GoogleApiClient,
on the PendingResult
that gets returned,
we set a Callback because we
want the result asynchronously.
In the Callback, we will
receive a Load People
Result, which is of type result.
So we can get the
status, and check
that the status
code is successful.
If all is well, then we can
obtain the list of people
that we're looking
for from the result.
To see the full example, go
to the List Visible People
Activity dot Java Class,
in the samples, in the SDK.
In conclusion, we are moving
towards a consistent model
of how to interact with
Google Play services.
See the documentation
for more details.
Existing services like
Games, AppState, Wallet,
and G+ have already
converted to the new model.
And more will be coming soon.
New services like
Chromecast and Drive
are already working with
the GoogleApiClient.
So try out Google
Play services today,
and see how it can
enhance your app.
Thank you for watching,
and see you next time.